I wanted to get my certifications our  company was putting a big focus on lean  six sigma and efficiency and it was that  my current job situation was coming to  an end I'm always a forward-looking  person and when I start seeing all those  dimension of efficiency I was like okay  right he's on the wall and I'm I was  like one of the first one I got in there  and did it in the company and it just  has paid off because of the course I  took I and now on the team called the  quality implementation excellence team I  my when I came with it I I come away  giving simply learn a gold star so the  things i saw that i liked were the  quality you know the quality was really  good then when i recommended this course  to my colleagues i told them that and  they came back and they said oh yeah i  took her from that instructor and our  learning styles weren't there I was like  don't worry about go to this check this  guy out and they went check that guy on  there like perfect